the first thing that drew me to my
husband his size and his heart
everything that he did it was for his
family helping others but it was for his
family too he he was just awesome and he
he wanted to pass that on to his kids
22 months ago December the 4th 2012 my
husband Dennis sparks Hill passed away
oh my goodness what happened he had a
stroke how old was he he was 29 years
old and what 29 29 29 years old
oh yes sir we never know when this is
gonna happen to any of us
it was a nightmare every day for the
first year I I became the protector the
provider for the kids
I felt the heaviness of the financial
situation it was very important to
fulfill Dennis's vision it would have
been just horrible from me not to not to
keep going with a plan it I wanted to
honor him
I just wanted to honor them is the way
he deserved to be honored
right after he passed away I just said
the goal for me and the kids to be
debt-free Wow and today we are here we
paid off the house after 22 months your
house yes sir in order to pay off for
depth we had to make sacrifices
we cut the cable off we got the internet
off my cellphone plan I just say goodbye
to them I just I just needed to get it
done fast as fast as I could it was also
helpful for my grief too and in two
years you paid off your house the kids
say they were a huge part of this
process too we were a good team before
when Dennis was here they knew that this
had a purpose they didn't complain we
did it as a family so I like that part
of it but I didn't like the sacrifices
that we had it do I want to thank last
but not least my children for being a
really good thing yeah yeah they are a
good team yeah yeah you can tell by
watching I just make the decision
I'm just doing it I'm by myself and I'm
gonna do it God is really good I I just
thank him every day and count my
blessings every day for his mercy and
for being our provider provider and our
protector after my husband passed away
and he very poor and he was always
watching over us I just couldn't stop
thinking about the kids about the legacy
that Dennis wanted to leave financially
speaking he wanted to do much more but
this is something that I could do I knew
that I was determined but I didn't know
how much I just felt so happy I feel
excited I feel relief I felt powerful I
did it we did it three two one
oh my gosh Wow oh man oh man
thank you Lord for work that matters Wow
I just kept on going with the plan and
the goals that we both set up
my husband he gave me a family he gave
me hope
he gave me love when we plant together
everything that he wrote down you I
still have it and I'm gonna do it I need
to for him for me for the kids for
family that way I can show him still
showing him my love for him
and